i
i'm loving the new show and i want to
get into all of it but of course i took
a step back because i love people's
bodies of work i was wondering um if i
could ask you about um some of your
projects that we've all loved over the
years drew barrymore can ask me anything
oh my gosh
well
how did i never get to work with you
barrymore in all my projects that's the
question i don't understand how we never
got lined up you know well there is
still time okay okay there you heard it
folks you've been in so many things that
i absolutely love let's get into them
i'd love to be a fly on the wall in a
favorite game i like to play called
behind the scenes
here we go
top soup oh yes look at that baby face
yes yes that was some hair
it was basically just a clip show where
you look at all the daytime talk shows
and and at first it kind of started like
a very straightforward show and then we
were like well
there's no way we can take any of this
very seriously it just started to get
bananas i remember going down to
disneyland and they ended up putting me
in the disneyland parade so i suddenly
had ears on
trying to be cool sort of anti-culture
talk soup guy but when you got the ears
on
that doesn't mean i don't want tickets
to disneyland let me be clear about that
but you're like i'm equal opportunity in
my ears exactly okay tell us about the
incredible remake of a beloved classic
with harrison ford and julia armand
sabrina ah sabrina
yeah it was my first uh first you know
movie opportunity we shot it actually
out in glen cove long island i i had
this white tuxedo on half the film and
down in long island the blue fish start
running around april or may and i love
fishing and i would go with my pole
down to the water's edge and i'm in that
white tuxedo down by the shore trying to
catch blue fish and i finally landed one
at the very moment because they were
always waiting and they were finally
like as soon as i got it up this this
scaly slithery beast in my hands they're
like greg we need you now
and i go up on uh go up on the thing and
and covered in fish scales and i got an
earful from the costume department oh
well the best story from sabrina
okay your oscar oscar-nominated role
as good as it gets yeah i remember going
to the oscars with i took my parents and
it was great uh it was you know honestly
it's just such a blur i didn't even know
like suddenly my mom's like honey how
are we getting there and i was like
i don't know
and then there was a limousine that
pulled up and i looked through the
window and i'm like oh my god this is
the most
horrific limousine i've ever seen i
think there was like a jacuzzi in the
back of it
and i was like and he's bumping in he
was bumping into like the garage and
trying to circumvent our driveway and i
was like okay there's no getting around
the show's starting in an hour i usher
my wife mom and dad my mom's like oh
look there's a disco ball and
it was so mortifying because he got to
the show and i just remember thinking
why can't i have a cool car like
everyone else
because life always throws those comedic
curve balls yeah i guess okay you've got
mail
yeah
nora ephron i wasn't chosen to do the
movie then i went and she said can we
get breakfast at you know e-a-t is that
what it's called yeah can i
it's aka for let me get you in my web i
think yeah i think you're right actually
she was kind of because it's such a cute
little place in the upper i think east
side you know you go in there and it's
like what are you going to do after you
sit down i'm having a lovely breakfast
with norah of course by the time i was
halfway through my coffee i'm doing that
yes because aka spiderweb e-a-t exactly
w-e-b-a-k-a-e-a-t
[Applause]
um i'm gonna go straight into the next
movie i love so much and you are such a
savior in it you have a heart of gold in
this movie little miss sunshine oh yeah
thanks
yeah
the most dangerous movie i've ever shot
it's like me driving that bus there's no
green screen we're on a highway there's
cameras we didn't own the highway so
there are people driving around just
looking at us going what the hell is
going on here so we just made it up as
we went along but that
that kind of independent gorilla
filmmaking was
kind of a gem of its time they don't do
that much anymore i love it i want to
turn the tables i want to ask drew barry
more about fever pitch because i always
like that oh yeah oh well
that
that is a very special uh film for me
because we were apart and witnessed the
breaking of the curse of the bambino 81
years at that point the red sox hadn't
won and the film was about were you
there at that game yes oh my gosh we
filmed we filmed the end of the movie on
the mound in st louis and and we thought
we were going to jinx them we were like
oh we're going to be the thing that gets
in the way of this team winning and then
we're filming the whole season and then
also jimmy fallon who is the lead fell
in love with my producing partner nan
who's my best friend in the world and
now they have two kids
and
i didn't know that yes
[Music]